dit pas son nom
tallinn
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on découvre les bougies
senteurs et lumière avant le concert des
litchis pour les âmes vagabondes onglets
avec nous
j'ai commencé en fait à la suite d'une
reconversion professionnelle parce que
j'étais dans le milieu médical et du
coup j'avais envie de faire quelque
chose de manuels mais je n'avais pas
encore quoi exactement est bêtement j'ai
vu une bougie sur mon meuble et ses
parties de linval
inspiration c'est la vie quotidienne je
regarde très souvent ce qui se passe
autour de moi et j'essaie de le
reproduire en syrie et les gens sont
quand même assez étonnés ils me disent
ah pas ça se mange
c'est ce que je recherche en fait c'est
de créer le trompe l'oeil dans
sur mes bougies voilà et généralement ça
marche je travaille sur des animaux j'ai
essayé de travailler suivant les
endroits j'ai notamment un dépôt vente
aussi lesté des tanneurs je vais
dépenser je travaille sur des petites
vaches
j'essaie toujours même adapté en
fonction de l'endroit où suis-je
donc les parfums moi je les prends chez
fragonard don qui est un grand parfumeur
de chez de grâce
avec qui un jour je vous reviens vite
j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion mais
j'aimerais bien
on peut retrouver les produits
notamment à boîtier donc à la maison du
tourisme et du terroir qui se trouve sur
un côté de la place dames à poitiers
j'ai aussi la maison de pays du lot
d'une haie qui se trouve à chalais soit
nationale a pris à center parcs
souvenez-vous du comptoir du poitou
appartenait donc au petit bonheur aux 35
genre jean jaurès donc avec mon ami à
qui on a créé au on a créé la boutique
et les gens ils savent que de toute
façon chaque expo que je fais où chaque
stand b y trouveront les nouvelles
choses même pour moi c'est important
parce que déjà ça permet de travailler
la création tout le temps que si on
tombe dans une routine
ben moi aussi je vais m'ennuyer quoi
force comme je suis labellisé en fait
marc fois tout ça permet aussi
de garantir la bonne qualité des
produits donc au niveau de la cire
naturelle des méchants plan des parfums
qui sont naturelles aussi et de
l'authenticité vannes les produits que
voilà on parle de quelque chose de
naturel et pas un chat
[Musique]